اول رئيس امريكي سابق سيمثل امام القضاء
لابلاغه رسميا بتوجيه تهم جنائيه عده لهم
لكن كيف تتم مساءله ترامب وما هي اجراءات
محاكمته
بدايه نشرت شرطه مدينه نيويورك عناصرها
وضباطها على الطرق العامه تحسبا لاي اعمال
شغب خلال محاكمه ترامب حيث من المقرر ان
ترافق الخدمه السريه ترامب الى مكتب
المدعي العام ومن ثم سيتم احتجازه لاخذ
بصماته وقد يتم التقاط صور له لحفظها
بالسجلات الرسميه وضع المتهم في زنزانه
وتكبير يديه بالاصفاد كما هو معتاد قبل
تقديمه للمحاكمه امر لن يحدث مع ترامب
سيتم نقله عبر ممرات خاصه مباشره الى قاعه
المحكمه محاطا بعملاء فيدراليين مسلحين
لحمايته وبعد تقديمه للمحاكمه سيواجه
ترامب التهمه الموجهه اليه رسميا وقد يتم
وضع شروط على سفره خارج امريكا